malgré ces joutes oratoires bon qui font
partie du jeu aussi des assemblées
parlementaires surtout regarder le fond
du dossier et cette loi est une loi d'
équilibre qui permet de protéger les
français et en même temps de lutter
contre la menace terroriste
le l'état d'urgence avec les critiques
et sa reconduction donc notamment
systématique
il est à mon avis intéressant d'essayer
de voir comment intégrer une partie des
mesures seulement une partie d'ailleurs
des mesures de l'état d'urgence dans le
droit commun sous le contrôle du juge et
du parlement afin d'en fois améliorer la
sécurité des français parce que la
menace terroriste est toujours là les le
poids est aussi d'assurer la sécurité
des transferts et les forces d'assurer
les forces le gouvernement a annoncé
beaucoup de recrutements pour les forces
de police et de gendarmerie
je note d'ailleurs que ceux qui
critiquent notamment à droite avaient
été ceux qui avaient déshabillé les
forces de police et qui avait la baisser
la garde
notamment en réduisant massivement des
effectifs de police où le gouvernement
sarkozy fillon il ya aussi des critiques
alors varier sur sur des points divers
notamment le contrôle élargis qui rendu
possible aux frontières là ça fait ça
provoque beaucoup de polémiques certains
y voient aussi une manière d'endiguer
l'immigration clandestine aux frontières
le texte porte sur la loi sur le
l'antiterrorisme donc c'est faux quand
j'entends dire que ça élargit énormément
le chant c'est une loi qui est consacré
d'ailleurs contrairement état d'urgence
consacrée aux chants de la lutte contre
le terrorisme et donc les mesures sont
restreintes à l'application 2 dans ce
cadre là je crois que c'est quand même
très important de le souligner par
ailleurs j'ai noté que certains
parlementaires voulaient faire des
propositions notamment sur l'évaluation
de la loi son contrôle etc
je crois que c'est une proposition
notamment du modem 6 g si j'ai écouté
les débats hier je pense que ce sont des
propositions y venaient faire des
propositions assez intensif d'avoir une
force de suivi des parlementaires sur
l'application de la loi mais tant dans
son contenu contestation sur l'état de
droit mais dans son contenu je la
partage
mais où franchement quand quand on se
regarde on se désole parfois quand on se
compare on se console
où est la difficulté est ce que les
libertés des français ont été réduites
un seul instant dans la période
précédente
est ce que la liberté de circulation de
manifester et de créer certaines encore
exactement quel cas d'accord c'est dans
ce jeu diront certains critiques de
cette loi sont par ailleurs des
thuriféraires du régime qui sont
extrêmement contestable du point de vue
des libertés
pardonnez moi de le dire notamment en ce
qui concerne la france insoumise pour le
régime de monsieur maduro au venezuela
et donc quand j'entends le soutien à ces
régimes là est par ailleurs des
critiques qui me paraissent infondées
sur un état de droit une démocratie
comme la france où nous avons vu toutes
les manifestations contre la loi travail
pendant cet état d'urgence donc je crois
qu'il faut être raisonnable nos libertés
ne sont pas menacés le juge contrôlera
une partie des mesures et nous devons
équilibrer à la fois